russia's army is pressing its attack on
kiev and other major ukrainian cities
showing targets that include residential
buildings and other institutions
sheltering civilians
to some
the tactics look familiar like a page
from russia's playbook in syria
indiscriminate bombardment of heavily
populated centers cluster munitions and
sieges all add up to a dirty war
inflicting widespread suffering reports
suggest battle-hardened chenchen and
syrian fighters are in fact joining the
russian forces fighting in ukraine
unto the point we ask war in ukraine
does putin want total devastation
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to welcome our guests liana fix
is a security and russian expert who
works with the berlin-based kerber
foundation
it's great to have kristen helberg with
us once again on the show she's a
freelance journalist who has reported
extensively from the middle east and
syria for german and swiss media
and joining us from bonn louis sanders
from dw's investigative unit
so let me ask all of you to tell us a
little bit about how you interpret what
we're seeing at the moment on the ground
and lyanna kiev kharkiv maria paul all
under heavy attack what are you hearing
about the extent of civilian and
military casualties on both sides
well moscow's initial campaign was very
much the idea to have a shock in our
campaign and to finish the war quickly
have a victory parade in kiev and that
was it this has not worked out and we
see casualties on the russian side which
amount to hundreds and thousands of
casualties unexpected by moscow so this
is now a shift in strategy russia could
not achieve its initial aims taking care
of regime change and now it's going for
the part that we've seen in syria to
terror against the civilian population
to
force kiev to make concessions in
negotiations because the pictures in the
way of warfare is just so brutal and
cool at the moment let me ask you about
those negotiations because we're seeing
or hearing conflicting signals on the
one hand we have the russian foreign
minister mr lavrov saying that he's
optimistic that the talks are making
progress on the other hand we have
president putin saying he's going to
prosecute this war to the end what do
you make of that discrepancy
it's an incredible difficult situation
for the ukrainian government to be in
because obviously they want to end the
the death and the terror that is taking
place in their country but moscow has
demonstrated in the past that you have
to look at what moscow does and not what
it says
so while in wetherwick they have toned
down their demands there's still very
much the possibility that that an actual
negotiations moscow will violate
agreements will continue to attack
civilian and military targets and will
also do that to force ukraine to further
concessions it's um a
a catch-22 situation for the ukrainian
government and forzalinsky at the moment
let me ask louis to talk a little bit
about what russia is doing
attacks on civilian
buildings residential centers cluster
munitions and summary execution of
combatants are those simply
the normal tactics in a nasty conflict
or something worse president biden in
the u.s has called president putin a war
criminal
well they're definitely not the norm
especially uh under the rules of war and
i think what we are seeing uh right now
is uh
russia is taking action in a way that um
they're they're going into areas
attacking places just indiscriminately
and uh we i think the most noticeable
way that we could see this is just
attacks on hospitals so the who has come
out and said you know we've seen more
than 50 more than 50 cases
of hospitals uh being attacked and so i
think this is a good indicator
especially because hospitals are
protected objects under the geneva
conventions and just generally speaking
international humanitarian law so so
when we look at what the situation is
and we look at what russia has done for
example in syria i think we could we
could very much see that there are
there's just no um
there's not a lot of discrimination
between combatants and civilians at the
moment thank you very much and we will
come back uh to the topic of war crimes
a little bit later but kristin let me
take us back to what we heard uh from
lyanna in regard to the fact that that
shock and awe concept certainly hasn't
played out now you've said elsewhere
that putin tends not to overreach that
that's a pattern you observed in syria
but in fact hasn't he overreached this
military campaign clearly isn't going as
he as he thought it would clearly
russia's military is not as adept as
many people believe them to be yes
definitely i mean he didn't overreach in
syria because the syria intervention was
unpopular in russia it was far away
people were not so much into
saving president bashar al-assad you
know back in russia so what he did there
was a very limited engagement from his
point of view he would send military
advices he would send his air force
which was very effective some naval
some naval troops but obviously in
ukraine it's not going the way that he
wished for
so he faces a lot of resistance he was
not counting was not expecting this but
he knows exactly how to break resistance
from syria how to break the resistance
especially of civilian population and
this is exactly what we are seeing now
in mariupol if you want to take control
of an area you seal it off
and you bomb it from the air on the
ground you bump civilian infrastructure
hospitals the theater in maliupu you've
just seen this then you cut off
electricity a theater that was
sheltering many many civilians
apparently
but do we have confirmation that in fact
that was targeted
we don't know yet but it said that it
has been targeted and that even there
was some alert putting that you said
this before the name of children in
russian on the ground to make sure that
it was not attacked the same happened in
syria the coordinates of hospitals were
given to the u.n to make sure that they
were not attacked and they were
deliberately bombed by the russian air
force so what i wanted to say is you
besiege an area you cut it off from
water from electricity from the internet
people would stay incommunicado with the
rest of the world and this is all to
make them agree in the end to their own
expulsion to displace the people through
these so-called humanitarian corridors
and in the end this is a form of ethnic
cleansing really because you make the
people leave the area it's easier to
control marijuana afterwards if half of
the population is already gone so this
is the same playbook exactly
then let's take a closer look at the
long and destructive russian
intervention in syria and whether in
fact it does hold lessons for the war in
ukraine
[Music]
images from 2016
eyewitnesses reporting a russian air
raid on a suburb of aleppo by then
russia had been bombing targets in syria
alongside the assad regime for months
the so-called fight against terrorism
killed thousands of civilians hospitals
schools and markets were targeted
incendiary vacuum and cluster bombs all
banned worldwide were also used
putin's air force shifted the syrian war
in assad's favor but the russian
president did not send in ground troops
he left the street battles up to assad
loyalist fighters
ukrainian president zielinski is now
warning of their intervention in his
country
thugs from syria from the country that
was destroyed in the same way that the
invaders are destroying us now
is ukraine facing a scenario like the
syrian war
and let me put that question to louis
and also ask whether you think that we
are seeing a change in russian tactics
for instance with this intensifying
aerial bombardment and what the lessons
from syria do in fact tell us about
where this may be heading
well indeed if
we look at the tempo of the invasion
right within the first couple days i
mean there was oh they i don't think the
the russian armed forces were expecting
the kind of resistance that they were
met with by ukrainian forces and so what
we're seeing now is this escalation
towards just bombing areas bombing
civilian uh cities urban centers where
there's a high risk of high civilian
casualties we've already started uh
seeing this with regards especially to
hospitals and i think what's interesting
in this regard is that
we can
begin to see um the kind of tactics that
the russian armed forces were using in
syria now for example
i think a good uh point that was raised
earlier was are are these intentional
attacks are these deliberate attacks and
i think there's a few parameters or
indicators that we can look at um to see
if that's the case now uh i think in for
example in hospitals you could see what
is the location what's their proximity
to military um uh sites or legitimate
military targets um we can also see if
an attack was conducted twice so for
example there's a lot of work that's
been done on the legal reflections of uh
double tap attacks so for example if an
airstrike hits a place and then a couple
of minutes or a couple hours later it's
hit again that that you oftentimes is a
is a good indicator especially for work
on prosecutors uh to say that there's
intent here and so what we're starting
to see
is this pattern emerge where uh you know
there are
very solid indicators that these that
there are deliberate attacks on these
civilian objects which are protected
under international humanitarian law
liana some experts draw analogies not
only to syria but also to the conflict
in chechnya
absolutely i mean just the pictures um
in chechnya were very similar the
indiscriminate bombing campaigns and
really the change of tactic from finding
any political solution to finding a
solution in the ground by sheer terror
and bombing so this is a pattern that
we've seen in russian foreign policy in
the past but no one would have expected
that this would apply to russia's
brother nation immediately in its
neighborhood and this is what makes it
so difficult to stomach um that this is
taking place in the middle of europe
while at the same time the west has only
limited means to stop vladimir putin
because there's concern about an
escalation two world wars we in case a
no-fly zone or other direct nato
military intervention takes place as
we've seen in the past in libya for
instance i want to come to the question
of uh escalation let me let me go back
to uh kristen and what you
observed in syria uh
you have said elsewhere that
you concluded on the basis of the syrian
uh conflict that putin is not a
strategist but a tactician
can you tell us what that means in terms
of the war in ukraine and where this
could be heading in in escalation
well in syria he proved to be very
flexible in his reactions towards the
very complex dynamic of the war in syria
for example whenever he saw a lack of
action from western countries he would
immediately step in and take the chance
and make it work for himself we had for
example the famous red light by
ex-president obama in 2013 when the
syrian regime attacked with chemical
weapons the outskirts of damascus and he
didn't want to send any troops or attack
back then so putin made it easy for
obama not to do anything because he said
okay we will talk to bashar al-assad and
we will make him give up his chemical
weapons program so he would in the end
he would promote himself as the big
diplomatic here he doesn't have a proxy
it's russian forces that's the biggest
difference and we have to explain this
maybe a little bit because his
intervention in syria is not against the
international law because assad himself
invited him to come for help so what is
illegal is the way of the kind of
warfare that we see there but maybe
because i think there's one very
important lesson that he learned from
his syrian experience and this is
important when you talk about escalation
putin
knew of or he understood from his syrian
experience that whenev whatever he does
on the ground be it a targeting civilian
civil infrastructure be it
indiscriminate telling of residential
areas he will get away with it as long
as no nato territory is involved so he
can do whatever he wants even in ukraine
this is what he feels like
without being confronted with any
military reaction so the fact that the
international community did not stop the
attack on civilians in syria it didn't
even sanction it by the means that we
are seeing now led to this fact that he
feels encouraged or he felt encouraged
in the first place to go to rookie and
to attack ukraine and to follow the same
playbook now
let me pick up on that but uh it do it
uh with a a slight detour namely to talk
about foreign fighters and the potential
that their presence could lead to
escalation and ileana in fact foreign
fighters are entering this conflict on
both sides we've heard
vladimir putin essentially inviting them
directly and also uh people like the
chechen leader uh mr ramzan khariff
saying that in fact he is in ukraine i
don't know if we have proof of that or
not but how do you see this impacting
the war
as you said we have foreign fighters on
both sides so the ukrainian military
created international legion where
internationals who want to support
ukraine in the war can join in response
the russian president and i think there
are two dimensions to is to this first
he wanted to demonstrate that russia has
also international support and has also
foreign fighters who support russia's
cause and therefore want to join the war
but on the other hand he also invited
foreign fighters to improve the war
effort because it was not going well it
is not going well and the use of
conscripts in russia is something which
is a very difficult issues because there
are these soldiers mothers in russia who
ask why are their sons not coming back
from the conscription so this is
a tactic both sort of on the military
side but also in the narrative side to
argue russia is not alone against the
world fighting this war um it has
international support and its cause is a
just cause which is obviously not what
almost the rest of the world believes
lewis let's talk about the uh the
ukraine side in fact we are seeing
europeans uh going into ukraine to join
the con the the the conflict uh on the
ukraine uh side germany has warned its
citizens not to go there what do we know
about how many european fighters are
there and could their presence provide
putin with an excuse
to say that essentially nato is
intervening in this conflict
well uh to answer the first part of the
question um
the the estimates right now i think
provided by the ukrainian government but
also kind of estimates that we've heard
also at the border um is between
anywhere between 16 to 20 000 but that's
a hard number to corroborate uh with
regards to how many foreign fighters are
coming into ukraine and wanting to fight
on the ukrainian side against russian uh
armed forces now um
could this be used uh from the russian
side as a sort of uh
how do we say as a justification to
continue uh the war or to escalate the
situation further um i i think they
would be hard-pressed to actually be
able to justify that in terms of legally
sound uh
options that they could have for kind of
pushing forward with that i mean there's
just nothing nothing to say that as long
as we don't see actual nato forces um
going in or member states taking kind of
unilateral action i think it would be
hard for putin to justify uh anything
that would come close to an attack on
nato territory
kristen
do respond to that if you like but let
me kind of up the ante a little bit in
terms of potential scenarios um if
russia sees increasing economic distress
and rising protests at home and there
are reasons to believe that he will see
both
if russian forces remain bogged down in
ukraine and we see a continuing flow of
weapons from western countries to the
ukrainian side would you expect vladimir
putin at some point to resort for
example to chemical weapons as did his
proxy mr assad
i think putin knows exactly that the red
line lies outside ukraine whatever he
does inside ukraine would not provoke
any kind of
nato involvement on the ground i guess
what we see already is this kind of
propaganda which is very important and i
see a big parallel here because the
propaganda in syria you always have to
delegitimize your enemy obviously to
explain your own strategies and your
warfare so in syria it was always this
fight against the terrorists now in
ukraine it's the fight against neo-nazis
and nationalists so this is very similar
concerning chemical weapons what
happened in syria is that russia
would
announce that they fear of a chemical
weapons attack by the rebels you know so
a few weeks later a few days later it
was the assad regime
using these chemical weapons itself so
this is what happened and it was
especially chlorine chlorgas
which is available everywhere and it
sinks down to the sellers which is very
problematic in besieged cities because
people would hide from the bombing and
from the air attacks they would hide in
the cellars the claude sinks down and
attacks and gets the people in their
shelters so this is a very very uh
terrible kind of warfare and this would
be
theoretically possible
but i'm i'm not saying that this is
going to happen i'm just alarmed by the
kind of propaganda and the
disinformation that we already see and
we are in fact seeing claims from russia
lyanna that the u.s and ukrainian
governments are operating a secret
military biological program adamantly
denied by the u.s and by nato the head
of nato says this could be a pretext for
russian escalation
would you agree
and under what circumstances could you
imagine putin using either a chemical
weapon or even possibly a tactical
nuclear weapon
we have learned in the past that we
should be really careful not crossing
anything off the list when it comes to
what
russia and the russian president putin
is willing to do
in the case of use of chemical weapons
there will probably not a military
reaction but the sanctions response on
russia would probably extend what we've
seen
in the past and russia knows with this
very well and they know that they're
already in a difficult economic
situation so in this case we will
probably see full central bank sanctions
oil embargoes gas embargoes because this
is really something which
would overstep a line when it comes to
the nuclear dimension moscow has used
nuclear signaling to try to deter the
west from economic sanctions and from
helping ukraine with weapon delivery so
is it a bluff
i would in this situation we've done
this in the past calling would putin
does a bluff we should not repeat this
mistake but we should sort of um
evaluate the the probability and of
course any nuclear probability that is a
little bit higher and is already a huge
a huge reason for concern but
what we've seen is that the united
states has reacted with restraint to
russia's announcement has not raised its
own alert levels
and russia also has a lot of
conventional means at its availability
before it has to resort to
a potential use of tactical nuclear
weapons so we should not cross this out
but at the moment there are many other
means available to moscow to achieve its
war games and war aims and it's doing
this
let me just ask you to pick up on the
point that kristin made essentially
saying she thinks as long as uh
what
happens in ukraine stays in ukraine so
to speak that we would not see an
escalation
into something that that would take us
to a nato uh russia conflict directly
but we have people
who know putin well like the former head
of the yucos oil company michael
korkowski who are saying that putin is a
thug and i quote with a habit of
impunity who continues to perceive the
west as weak and will not stop until
confronted with a clear demonstration of
strength
how can the west provide such a
demonstration of strength in this
situation without triggering that uh
conflict between nato and russia
a demonstration of strength towards
ukraine is limited to economic means and
that is what the west is doing sanctions
in a speed that we've not seen at any
point in the past against a power that
is so embedded in the global economy so
this is the reaction towards ukraine and
this is the line there will be no no-fly
zone there will be no direct military
involvement the us has been very clear
on this again and
would say that's a mistake
that is an argument that one can make
but the and it's incredibly difficult to
wait
quite the crimes that are taking place
in ukraine
against the threat of nuclear escalation
i mean it's morally an incredibly
difficult choice to take but nato is a
defense alliance so what nato does at
the moment is to strengthen its eastern
flank to project exactly that strength
that mr horowski spoke about and to move
from deterrence by posture
um these couple of thousands u.s
soldiers there to an actual presence in
the east to signify to moscow that this
is an actual wetland so nato's eastern
border is the red line that nato would
be willing to use
to risk world war three we have very
little time but let's return very
quickly to the question of whether legal
and diplomatic initiatives offer an exit
ramp and no less than three
international courts are now
investigating alleged russian war crimes
and breaches of international law in
ukraine and one has already ruled the
international court of justice in the
hague has ordered russia to halt its
attack immediately the highest court of
the united nations ruled that russia is
in violation of international law and
says it sees no evidence justifying
russia's claim that it is that its
military operation is necessary to
defend russian speakers in the donbass
region of ukraine but the court has no
police or enforcement powers so will its
ruling make a difference and i'll just
ask lewis to please
answer that briefly because i know you
have done quite a bit of research on war
crimes
absolutely i i think uh with the icj the
international court of justice what you
were talking about i i think it's it's
important to note that they're dealing
with states and where i if we could see
any kind of prosecuting prosecution
moving forward with regards to
international crimes atrocities crimes
against humanity war crimes that would
likely be happening with something like
the international criminal court and i
think it's important to note here so do
their rulings
do their rulings actually make a
difference for conflict resolution if
not in the short term at least later on
i i'm
i honestly i'm unsure i'm not sure it's
going to make a difference to putin
though i think what we can say though is
that when we do look at the
international court and the efforts that
they're doing and also some of these
other courts in germany for example with
universal jurisdiction i think what we
what we can say though is that they are
moving forward with this idea that we we
would gather evidence in order to try
perpetrators and in this case that could
even be someone like president vladimir
putin and kristen very briefly if you
would but if we look at the diplomatic
negotiations whether it's the ones
occurring in under the sponsorship of
belarus or turkey or even eu member
states do you think they can offer an
exit ramp that would in fact prompt
putin to de-escalate not yet i think
right now russia is not interested in
any negotiation solution and we have
seen the same patterns in syria
negotiations keep on going on for years
in geneva in astana wherever this is
happening now because to putin until now
he has no success in ukraine that he
could sell back at home so he wants to
continue he wants to create facts on the
ground militarily first and then impose
any kind of solution in from his mind to
the ukrainian side meaning we will be
returning soon to this topic thank you
very much to all of you for being with
us and thanks to you out there for
tuning in